reculer vous
pendant les six prochains mois
nous ne serons plus qu'un jet de lumière
déchirant l'espace et le temps
et ceux qui sont cryogénisé croiront
avoir répété ce voyage sera synonyme de
vie
première fois
tu veux un conseil d'ami casse toi mon
siège
ne vous exposez pas sans compter
tout le monde est mort et 50 millions
personnes
les derniers 50 millions si tu remarques
un comportement étrange mais tu me le
dis tout de suite
[Musique]
ils ne sont pas seuls
alors menti
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce qu'on mérite
s'ils sont là on voit les éliminer
une force nouvelle contrôle et de
l'intérieur il n'est pas humain on y va
vous dégagez de ce vaisseau nous sommes
là pour traquer
nous sommes là pour survivre